what is a justification a justification
is a set of reasons why something like a
belief or a claim or an action is true
or reasonable or good justifications are
often conflated with explanations an
explanation is a set of reasons why an
event or a belief came to be think back
to my video on normative versus
descriptive claims a justification
attempts to make normative sense of
something a justification tries to
rationalize whether something has a
certain quality or adheres to a value my
claim is true it has the quality of true
Ness and adheres to the value of truth
because of a B and C an explanation
tries to make descriptive sense of
something an explanation tries to
describe how something came to be based
on objective facts this event happened
because of XY and Z so let's say this I
say to you why is God real justify the
existence of the Abrahamic God and you
say back to me that's just how I grew up
my parents are Methodist I always went
to church so it's what we believe this
is not a justification for the belief in
the existence of God or a justification
for the trueness of Christian and
Methodist beliefs
it's an attempted explanation of how you
came to believe what you believe an
actual attempt to justify the existence
of God might be for you to start talking
about I've seen God perform miracles the
universe can't come from nothing here's
some direct historical or archaeological
evidence for the resurrection of Jesus
etc sometimes a justification for an
event can use some of the same facts
that would be used to explain that event
but justifying and explaining are still
different because a justification is
always going to make normative appeals
while an explanation is merely
descriptive
and that is the difference defending why
something is true or good versus
describing how something happened if
you're interested in philosophy and
critical thinking you will love
brilliant which has pretty much become
my go-to for learning things online
check out brilliance new immersive
lessons on logic problem-solving
multi-level thinking identifying false
information and identifying fallacies
whether you already have a grasp on any
of these subjects or you're looking for
a fun and engaging way to become
acquainted with these topics for the
first time brilliant really is the place
to go where you can actually learn
hands-on by solving problems and puzzles
designed by expert educators and unlike
other learning sites when I'm using
brilliant I'm actually learning by
working hands-on with real-world
scenarios and problems sign up for free
by going to brilliant org slash critical
thinking I've put a link in the
description under this video and the
first 200 people who visit will get 20%
off an annual Premium Membership visit
brilliant org slash critical thinking